i put up a video every day um and i've
done it for like nine years
every conceivable thing you could do
wrong i've done at least once like you
know
forgot to start um you know had my
microphone plugged into my headphone
jack like every possible thing you could
screw up it's like i found a way so
i've just checked my levels and they all
look good so i think um
i'm ready when you are
[Music]
my name is eddie wu my channel's name is
wutube
and what i put up on my channel are
recordings from my everyday
classroom lessons because i'm a high
school mathematics teacher
years ago i taught a student who became
very very sick he was diagnosed
with pancreatic cancer and was missing
weeks and weeks of school either
in hospital receiving treatment or at
home recovering
and for me knowing what it was like
being a student myself and
having trouble understanding mathematics
just by reading a textbook
i wanted to give him more i wanted him
to feel like he could participate in
learning
with his peers and so back then i just
reached out into my pocket pulled out my
phone and started recording
my lessons very very low tech in fact
when you go back and have a look at
those original videos
they're pretty poor quality but what i
quickly discovered was that it was a
fantastic learning resource
not just for this one young man who was
learning from home
but also for my students who are in the
class to revise even for students in
other classes other schools even around
the country and the world
who actually got to tune in learn at
their own pace and in a way that suited
them so that's kind of
where my channel began and the life that
it's now taken on
i started my channel because i have a
passion for learning it's why i became a
teacher in the first place
but when i had one student who
contracted a very serious illness cancer
i wanted to continue learning while he
was from home and in hospital
and the videos were a way for him to
access the classroom and continue
studying with his buddies
some of my videos have become wildly
popular which is completely shocking to
me because it's just what i do every day
i don't think very carefully about will
this video go viral but
you never know what's really going to
strike someone's curiosity so
a couple of my videos that have gone
like multi-million views they're about
questions that really drive everyone
crazy and everyone wants to know the
answer and i just love explaining
and peeling back the veil on why things
are true in mathematics and not just
that they're true
when i consider my most popular videos
thinking about trying to give creators
advice about what they should make
videos about
i definitely think about making ideas
that are complicated
simple trying to provide access to a
world like mathematics which most people
would think is like
completely inscrutable and hard to
understand but actually
putting that in language and with
metaphors and illustrations that
anyone can come along watch and enjoy i
think that's certainly been one of the
secrets
to why my videos have been popular if
you're trying to work out
what topic or area or idea you should
make videos about
the one piece of advice i can give is
that make it authentically
you for me learning and mathematics and
other things like playing the guitar or
trying to understand how to study these
are just part of my own life and what my
brain is ticking about and i'm
passionate about them
and i think that comes through in the
videos and viewers can tell
that's real it's authentic and that's
what's always going to gain traction
with people who are watching
i get asked all the time about what
equipment i use to shoot with and how i
actually have my workflow and all that
kind of thing
and i always want to say to every
creator the equipment i'm happy to
answer questions about and tell you
exactly what i use
but the equipment isn't what people are
coming to watch for they're not after
production values
they're after you and what makes you
tick and what's really
important to you and what you're excited
to talk about so you know i started
just with my phone and it was pretty you
know nasty quality
but you could still see me through that
so even as my production values have
increased over the years
and i've upgraded microphones and lights
and stands etc
the thing that really is that the
heartbeat of the channel isn't about the
equipment it's about you
as a person and what you want to show
and talk about there are two different
kinds of community that i engage with
through youtube the first one is the
community that already exists around me
that helps me to create
these videos and that's my classroom and
i want to say i think part of why the
videos that i make
are engaging is because they have to be
engaging to the people in front of me
the people i'm talking to
because sometimes teenagers can be a
pretty tough audience especially in a
mathematics classroom
the second audience is the one that i've
reached all around the world
that i would never be able to interact
with or even meet
if not through youtube and i love to be
able to post things to answer questions
to be able to engage on all kinds of
different social media and put things
out there in the conversation
that people can engage with ask
questions and uh to be able to have that
back and forth so
across all different platforms that's
what i really enjoy doing i really love
how much data i have access to
through youtube's analytics i guess
that's not surprising because i'm a
mathematics teacher so numbers are my
jam but for little things like
when people are watching my videos or
how they actually consume the different
parts of the videos i create one of the
things i often do
is i'll edit videos and then upload them
in batch and i used to just
hit publish on all of them all at the
same time because i was like done and
then people can view it as quickly as
possible
but i realized fairly quickly if i put
10 videos up all at the same time
people will watch one of them and then
they just won't have time for the other
nine so
now i use the scheduling tools in the
back there to be able to you know space
them out and people can consume them at
a rate that actually makes sense for
them
i wouldn't know that without youtube
analytics
one of the most surprising things i got
from my analytics was actually noticing
the time of day
that people are watching a little while
ago i settled into the
one video a day upload cycle but i sort
of did them for my own
time zone i would put them in the
morning when i thought people would be
watching
but i was really surprised number one by
the fact that even locally
sometimes people watch late into the
evening when i wouldn't expect them to
be
and number two i now have people who are
viewing from all around the world
in fact only a small proportion of my
viewers are from australia the country
that i live in so being that everyone's
in all different time zones i learnt a
lot from when people are actually
watching
just by paying attention to the data and
noticing sometimes people would like
watch more
carefully and they would watch the end
of the video if i did it in time zone
that suited them
there have been a few turning points in
my channel that have changed the way
that i do things
i remember early on i was really
obsessed with video resolution i thought
if i can get the image to be really
clear
that's what people really value but then
one day i actually borrowed a microphone
from a friend and plugged it in
and my students the next week said wow
what did you change it is so much
clearer and easier to understand
and that's when i realized how important
sound is especially when you have highly
verbal content
like i often do because i'm explaining
some pretty complicated concepts
one of the pieces of advice i'd give to
all creators is definitely to take the
time
to find your voice when i began i just
straight up was imitating some of the
youtubers i really admired
and that's not a bad place to start even
though those videos i look back and i
cringe because they don't sound like me
at all
but if i hadn't tried that out and then
gone through all these different styles
i wouldn't found the me that sounds like
me and there's no shortcut to that
you've just got to make lots and lots of
videos and you might
look at it and watch it back and think
do i really sound like that
but be patient with yourself that
crafting of a persona that is you
but it's a form that works through the
camera that takes time so be patient
and get there it's the best payoff once
you arrive
if you're a creator who wants to make
better and better videos
my advice is better quality comes in the
doing you've just got to give it a go
and make lots of videos sometimes tens
scores hundreds of them to actually
develop that skill
and find who you are it wasn't mainly by
watching things or by reading things
that i
improved my skill it was just by doing
lots of videos making lots of mistakes
and then learning from them be patient
with yourself and persevere
when i first started putting videos on
youtube i have to be honest
i was quite intimidated video editing
always seemed like something
super hard like you needed a university
degree or some
dark book of incantations so you could
say the right you know words that would
make your computer magically create the
video
but what i actually discovered was that
using very simple tools starting from
the bottom just like
imovie on my phone and doing the most
basic cutting and transitions and all
that kind of thing
that's where i began and then developing
those skills very gradually
over time and now i'm using final cut
pro on a mac
and i can do all kinds of advanced
things that i never would have imagined
before
but now having developed those skills
over time and built them up gradually
they become second nature so what i
would say is start off simple
and develop the skills over time you
never know where you'll be able to end
up
the very first video that i made i got
my phone out
and i didn't have anything else that i
could video with and i tried to set it
on a table
and you know just hit go and i always
kept knocking the camera over and i was
like oh this is not really working
so i had to go down to the wood workshop
at the school where i teach
and i just knocked together a few bits
of wood so i could put the phone in this
little slot so it would stand up and be
stable
and i was like oh this angle is all
wrong so i had to put a chair
on top of a table it was really unstable
and dangerous and then
i put my phone on top of that and then i
pressed record and then i was like oh
now i have this really long video file
what am i going to do with it and so i
went and
purchased like the most basic editing
software i could find on the app store
that would let me like
chop off the beginning and the end and i
took that and then i uploaded it to
youtube
well i tried actually i think my phone
died you know the battery died like five
times before i was like i better plug
this thing in
um and it was a pretty low quality video
but it worked and i i played it and i
was like whoa
i can watch this on my computer and it
was kind of this this thrill
actually when i'd created something and
you could put it out there and
anyone could watch it and i remember the
very first time actually when
i think the video must have hit like
seven views and
i only remember that number because i
know i'd watched it six times and i was
like
hold on someone else watched my video
like who's actually doing this and the
the realization that there was an
actual audience and it was somewhere out
there um was
really exciting and thrilling and to
know i could actually help people from a
distance
um was one of the best experiences i've
ever had and i still get to have
so it's been many years now since i
started my channel and
today i have more than a million
subscribers
something like 80 million views and like
a couple hundred thousand views every
single day
kind of boggles my mind like every time
i will look it's like whoa
the view count and the number of hours
that people have spent watching
it just goes on and on and on and one of
the really big things to me is actually
the fact that when i think about
watch time as a teacher i stand in front
of my class
about 800 hours per year so over the
course of say a
30 year career that's something like
well uh 24 000 hours if i can get to the
end
and you know don't fall over in a heap
that'll be an amazing achievement
um but the fact is that my channel has
actually been watched
uh hundreds and thousands of times
more like multiplied than i'd ever be
able to teach
in a lifetime and so to know that i can
have that kind of impact
not just around the world but also in
terms of the number of people that i can
just
reach um that i would never be able to
interact with face to face
to me that's just astonishing and even
as a numbers person it kind of boggles
my mind to think about these
astronomically large quantities uh it's
a real privilege to have that kind of
opportunity
if you're an educator thinking about
getting onto youtube the first thing i'd
say is
if you have any doubts absolutely go for
it i never thought there'd be a wide
audience out there who would be
actually interested in spending their
own time voluntarily
to watch the regular classroom teaching
that i do every single day there's
nothing special about it
i don't like plan out something
incredible and like do it for the video
i'm doing it for my students
and to know that that's actually the
thing that's had tremendous value to
students and parents and other educators
around the world
i definitely did not expect that and
it's one of the things that motivates me
to keep going but beyond that what i
would say is that every single educator
their best resource are the other
teachers they get to work with and to
know that there may be someone down the
hall in your school
or maybe in your community but to have
access to people around the world whose
perspectives
and methods and knowledge you can access
that's amazing and
you can contribute to that is something
i think you should take really seriously
i know that i've had the opportunity to
not just speak to
you know conferences of thousands of
teachers but even to
senior level decision makers i've met
the premier and the prime minister of my
country and of
other countries too who want to know
about education and how to do it
effectively
and to know that i have that opportunity
because they know about me
through my videos that's just
astonishing so i would say
the sky's the limit don't expect you
know that you'll you'll have a little
impact here um think big and you never
know what you'll be able to
achieve when i started putting my videos
online i wasn't really sure who was
going to watch
but i thought it would be students
because that was my target audience
people
who i was teaching who wanted to learn
stuff something i did not expect at all
was that fellow educators other
classroom teachers would be watching in
and i only found out because they
started to comment and they would say
hey i'm an educator from canada or
brazil or from mozambique and i really
love these videos please put up more
and it came to me that i re could
actually put up content that was
specific to teachers
so i created a second channel where the
content is dedicated to them
it's stuff that students would have zero
interest in where i talk about like why
did i plan a lesson this way or
what kind of resources or activities
that i use within the classroom
and have found that really useful and
have gotten really wonderful feedback
from it
because i've been a teacher for many
years it's often the case that i teach
the same concept or skill
many many years in a row but one of the
things that i love about putting stuff
up
online is that because i know i've
taught it a particular way once before
and there's a video for that
i can say to my students okay guys i'm
going to teach it to you a new way i'm
going to experiment
if you don't like this way that's okay
go back there's a video you can have a
look at
but we're going to go out on a limb try
something new and then if you like that
now you've got
two different ways to understand the
same idea and it's not just two
sometimes i will take the same idea and
look at it from 100 different angles
and it really puts a challenge on me to
teach in a new way to be novel
and creative and i love that i can
always have this parachute that i can
pull from my students
if you like my classic way go back it's
there as a video
but it lets me discover new things
because i can take creative risks